good morning
everyone welcome to the Friday sessions
of NDC the last day thanks for sticking
around on know these multi-day
conferences go on the attendance seems
to drop off so you know thanks for
thanks for sticking around so long and
specifically thank you for coming to
this session in this session we're going
to be talking about the top five ways to
make the worst microservice system ever
and hopefully with a clickbait title you
kind of got the idea that this is going
to be a bit of fun we're going to have a
good time some of us will laugh some of
us might cry as we see parts of our
systems in these techniqu
um but hopefully it'll be a good time
I'm very passionate about building bad
systems so I hope that some of that
passion comes through and elevat
energizes the room a little bit so that
maybe if you spent a little too long at
the cocktail party last night you'll
leave in a better mood than you came in
it I quite like this picture as a visual
representation of microservices uh the
contrast isn't great but it's a it's a
gentleman on a scooter and you can tell
he's going really fast because there's a
motion blurred background behind him um
just like microservices they they let
you move fast and you can be agile and
you can respond to changes uh you'll
also see that he doesn't have any bloat
on him he's only got the essentials his
uh his shoes his clothes his backpack
his hair that I'm totally not envious of
at all um but he doesn't have any bloat
on him such as I don't know uh knee
guards or elbow pads or protective head
gear of any kind um and that in
conjunction with this High center of
gravity and the low pivot point of the
scooter means he's only one bump in the
road away from permanent brain damage
just like
microservices so who am I and why am I
qualified to talk to you about building
bad systems my name is William Brer uh
my friends call me William and since
we've known each other for so long you
we're all friends here now so you also
get to call me William as you can see
from the mug I am the world's okayest
programmer uh there are unfortunately
three things that I don't like about
that mug the first is that the a program
is tilted just a little to the side just
enough for me to notice when I'm
drinking my tea or coffee the second is
that the font is dangerously close to
Comic Sands but it's not actually comic
Sands because that would be cool in a
sort of ironic way this is just a cheap
knock or font um and the third is that
unfortunately the mug is unverified I
know it it may come as a surprise but
there was not in fact a worldwide
programability survey done where they
assess the ability of every program
around the world and decided I was the
okayest unfortunately that didn't happen
so even though I'm in possession of the
mug it doesn't confer upon me the
official title of world's K
programmer so to look for some more
evidence of my okayness I went to see
what my co-workers were saying about me
um and as you can see in our company
slack they they don't think I'm the
worst programmer at least but they
definitely don't think I'm the best
programmer but what has been an okay
program I have to do with anything well
being okay means that I've written some
good systems and some bad systems in my
career but I'm pretty sure we all think
that we've written some good and some
bad does anybody El think they've never
written a bad
system if if you're hiring now is a time
when you need to look for Hands by the
way there's there's a couple in the back
there so what do I bring to the table
what can I offer you that will elevate
my expertise in building bad systems to
and take it to the next level well
that's got to do with who I work for and
I've got to be very careful how I phrase
this because just because I work for
them doesn't mean that we write bad
systems I work for a company called
particular software and particular
software makes n service bus which is a
framework and corresponding set of
libraries and tools that help Net
developers distribute their systems so
whether you want to do that to achieve
microservices or you want to do high
availability or service oriented
architecture whatever the reason n
Service Plus can help.net developers do
that
successfully the thing with working for
particular is that there's no
distinction between the engineering team
and the support team so if you work on N
service bus you support n service bus
and I do a lot of support because
honestly it's one of the more fun things
that I get to do in my job because you
get to see a lot of different types of
systems applied in a lot of different
environments in a lot of different ways
and a lot of different scales with one
might think a lot of different quality
levels of each of these
systems but here's a thing about system
quality if you assume that the quality
of systems around the world so we take
all the systems around the world and we
rank them in terms of quality you might
think that it would follow something
like a normal distribution where on the
one side you'd have very few systems
that are exceptionally high quality
these are pristine works of art we
should be preserving these systems and
studying them for decades to come on the
Other Extreme you might think there'd be
a few systems that are absolutely
atrocious and we should probably be
studying them for decades to come as
well but for a very different reason to
those and then you would think that most
systems sort of fall into the okay
system quality category but when you do
in support the people that have got the
good systems don't come to you and ask
for help because they don't need it
everything's going great the people that
have got the okay systems don't come to
you very often for support because
generally things are just going okay you
know they're doing just fine so the
types of systems that I see when do
support are the ones down here the ones
where there have been some bad decisions
that have been made system has been
architectured poorly things are going
wrong and they need help and after
seeing a lot of these types of systems
eventually you start picking out some
common themes among these systems and
that's what we're going to talk about
today in fact because I only see systems
in this section of the system quality
graph as far as I'm concerned the
distribution of system quality doesn't
look like this as far as I'm concerned
everything is skewed down to the awful
side and we should feel ashamed as an
industry of what we're doing to our
customers especially given how much some
of us are able to charge
them so microservices right why do we
microservice well the consultant answer
is we would do microservice so that we
can have independent deployability we
can have increase scalability we can
decrease coupling we can blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah nobody does
microservices for those reasons we do
microservices because we don't want to
do a monolith somehow as an industry we
have convinced ourselves that the two
options are either microservices or
monolith and on top of that monolith is
bad that's like saying well okay which
color are you going to use to paint the
black or the white ignoring the fact
that there's many other colors out there
and even if there were only the black
and white you're also ignoring the fact
that you can blend the black and the
white together to achieve Many Shades of
Gray in between it's not a one or the
other
discussion but somehow as an industry we
have collectively decided monoliths are
bad and you're only doing monoliths or
microservices nothing in
between go
progress uh some of these other answers
are quite fun though uh so why do you do
microservices because you want to
increase complexity and decrease
performance that's very very often the
case it seems like sometimes we come in
up with a most convoluted complicated
way to render little angle brackets down
to a browser for
HTML um someone wants to mend their
broken heart maybe maybe your heart's
been hurting I don't
know
so uh this picture on the left hand side
is a picture of the kalash temple in
India it is carved from a single Rock
making it the largest official man-made
monolith in the world uh here's another
image of it a slightly different angle
um you can see on the right hand side
there's a few people standing there to
give you an idea of the scale of this
thing this is this is a phenomenal work
of human achievement like they they had
to carve this by hand well I mean not by
hand they didn't claw away at the rocks
with their their fingers they had tools
but not like pneumatic tools or electric
tools or anything like that so this is a
phenomenal bit of human achievement that
we've done um the amount of work and
dedication that it must have taken to
construct this monolith is amazing the
Erp system that you've been working on
for 10 years doesn't even come close to
the scale of engineering needed for this
they had to to to design this in order
to construct it they had to start from
the top down they had to carve
everything away from the top everything
had to be planned in advance it was this
is this is an amazing feet of human
engineering that we've got you monoliths
can be
beautiful it must have been a labor of
love except for the people that worked
on it they must have gotten real sick of
chising their way after the first 5
minutes in the hot
Sun Also I can't help but wonder what
this would have looked like if it was
built using
scrum I guess we'll never
know so for the rest of the talk we're
going to work with a single example and
we're going to see how bad we can make
this example so we're going to start
with a monolith right and we're going to
transition this monolith to
microservices and we're going to see how
bad of a system we can get by taking
this to microservices and we're going to
see if we can make this an awful
experience to work with spoiler alert is
pretty bad straight from the first
technique but we can get it really bad
later on so because it's a monolith uh
remember our earlier discussion
monoliths are bad so this must be a tire
fire that we're working with now the
first technique we're going to use to
transition away from the monolith into
microservices is something known as the
Strangler fig pattern I'm pretty sure
most of us have heard of the Strangler
fig pattern by now but if you haven't
what the Strangler fig pattern says is
that when you want to transition
something to microservices you start by
carving off bits of functionality and
once you've taken that functionality you
can then extract it out to its separate
service so we'll isolate a bit of
internal functionality maybe something
like the charge credit card service once
we've isolated that within our monolith
we can then take that functionality and
move it to a separate micros service and
then we can call that micros service
instead of calling the code directly and
at this point we can we can Pat
ourselves in the back because we have
now achieved
microservices uh and we can order a
pizza party or whatever business is
doing for us these days to celebrate
successes but what have we actually done
to our system
performance so let's take a look at a
graph and what we'll do is we'll we'll
look at the throughput of the system and
how it changes based on the load of the
system and we'll first start with the
monolith so this is before we make any
changes to the system as we increase the
load of our monolith we should expect
the throughput of the monolith to
increase at a roughly linear rate now I
don't mean one to one when I say linear
I mean like some K value probably
between zero and one where as you
increase the load by one the throughput
will increase by x amount or k amount
whatever that
is as we increase the load even more
though there's a higher chance that
there's going to be contention of
resources there's going to be more
swapping of threads because it's taken a
little bit longer for things to complete
we're doing more things per time unit
but each of those things is going to
start taking a little bit longer maybe
there's roow locks that we've got
there's contention on resources
so we start seeing a sort of tapering
off of the increase in the throughput of
the system when the load gets to a
certain point at some point though if we
increase the the load of the system too
much we're going to see the throughput
completely drop
off
why why would you expect this to happen
so I'm a net developer so what I'll do
is I'll explain how this why this would
happen in net but this will work or this
will apply regardless of uh what
language you're using if it's a managed
runtime environment where they do some
type of garbage collection for you
something like this is going to occur
when your systems get to a certain
amount of load so in net there are three
types of garbage collection events
generation zero garbage collection
generation one and generation two and
net makes a few assumptions around
garbage collection uh that it builds its
garbage collection methodology off
of so if. net decides it needs to do
garbage collection the first thing it
does is decide what type of garbage
collection do I need to do um and that's
because the assumption is that variables
that are assigned to the Heap are very
quickly released or can be released
again uh shortly afterwards and they
represent that by doing a generation
zero garbage collection event so as soon
as you create a variable VAR aal1 123 uh
net will go and assign that bit of
memory to the Heap and it it puts it in
the generation zero category so when a
gen zero garbage collection event runs
it goes to everything as marked as
generation zero and says well is
something still referencing you no I can
release you is something still
referencing you no I can release you if
it gets to one that's still been
referenced it then takes that generation
zero memory and promotes it to
generation one so it's not going to
release it but the Assumption here is
that generation one is going to run less
frequently than a generation zero
garbage collection event and if you're
still using something while I'm trying
to uh clear up memory it's probably
going to hang around for a little bit
longer so as our as our system takes
longer to do things things hang around
longer which means we reserving that
memory longer which means that the
higher likelihood that those things are
going to get promoted to generation one
if things take even longer and a
generation one garbage collection event
runs it's going to go through all the
items marked gen zero and gen one so
immediately a generation one garbage
collection event takes longer than a gen
zero but it's going to go through all of
the Gen one items and see can I release
you can I release you can I release you
if it can't release it it's going to
promote it to surprise surprise
generation 2 and that's sort of where
the problem begins so generation two
garbage collection events in net or what
is known as stop the world events what
it does is it pauses all user threads so
if your application is processing 100
different threads all of those threads
are going to be paused except for the
one during the Gen 2 garbage collection
event which means you're not processing
anything stack Overflow experienced this
a few years back or many years back not
a few um and this is a graph showing the
response time of the web servers these
spikes over here that you can see these
are where the Gen 2 garbage collection
event was running and Mark reel wrote a
whole blog post about how they managed
to work around that
eventually since these days though so
this was 2011 things have improved a lot
with garbage collection in net uh We've
now got the background garbage
collection uh processor which goes and
does this in the background so it
doesn't pause all of the user threads
unless your system is under sufficient
load that net decides it needs to do a
foreground garbage collection event in
which case pauses all user threads and
You' get a drop off in
performance so that's why we would we
expect to see this drop off performance
in a monolith um under a certain amount
of load what happens when we transition
to microservices well well let's start
increasing the load of our
microservices at the beginning we should
start seeing a SL a linear is increase
in the throughput of our microservices I
hope it's obvious that the increase in
throughput will be lower than the
monolith because we've introduced
network operations right network
operations are expensive in terms of
computing time it takes a long time to
negotiate that TCP connection to do this
ceric exchange to serialize to
deserialize so we should see things
taking a little bit longer for the same
amount of
load okay well that means things are
going to hang around longer which means
we're going to get more thread swapping
sooner which means that decrease in
increase decrease of the increase of
throughput is going to come sooner which
Sur surprise means the big drop of
performance is going to come
sooner so the first technique that we
can do when we when we try to uh make
our system as bad as possible the first
technique that we can do is we can
actually try and do
microservices so for the first one you
put a net to call in front of everything
and that's a guaranteed way to make your
system a little bit just a little bit
worse is anyone you old enough to
remember the WCF days and there were
those people going around saying
everything should be a WCF data service
everything should be a data contract or
data object whatever it was yep man what
a time to be
alive so uh We've take we've taken our
system we've applied the Strangler fig
pattern all over the place and we no
longer have a monolith anymore we've now
distributed our system into a
microservice the thing that the
Strangler fig pattern is not good at
though is changing application logic or
fixing any coupling problems that you've
got so if you had coupling between code
components you're still going to have
that same coupling between your service
components now and in fact we've made it
worse because on top of the normal
application coupling that we had we've
now also got Network topology coupling
because we can't go and move these
services around without telling the
other services hey we've moved it around
so we've taken our monolith we split it
up and we've made it even worse by
making it a distributor monolith so
instead of a single tire that's burning
we've got a field of tires that's
burning which is pretty good so in terms
of progress for making the worst system
possible this is a this is a good first
step but now if you're working on this
system it's going to be pretty bad to
work you're going to hate your job
you're going to come in do your 8 hours
and then leave and probably Bang Your
Head on the desk a few times and you're
going to I'm almost into bet find
yourself thinking I bet you I could
rewrite the system in a few months and
it would be great anybody ever thought I
bet you I could rewrite the system and
i' fix all the problems you're all lies
if you haven't put your hand
up so rewriting the system is a is a
very enticing option sometimes because
it's difficult to work with this Legacy
that you drag in along with you but the
thing with rewrites is that big bang
rewrites of large complex software
systems do not
work asterisk and we we'll kind of
circle back to that asterisk in a bit
but rewriting a big large system is
probably not going to be a good idea and
it's probably going to fail why is that
well that's because of how we do
software development so software
development in its Essence is exchanging
time for functionality you're taking
developer time and converting that
developer time into features that users
can use so we can we can represent that
as a graph so on the y- axis we've got
the amount of functionality in the
system and the x-axis is the time spent
developing on the system
sometimes we uh sometimes we render this
as burn down charts you know but it's
essentially we're taking developer time
and converting it into
functionality and at the start of a
system things are going great when
you've got a green field system the
amount of time that you spend working on
your system means that you get a high
output in terms of functionality that
you can add you're throwing new screens
out left right and Center your your
users are very happy with this
eventually you get to a point though
where you need to sort of go back to
previous functionality that you've
worked on you have to pay some technical
debt maybe refactor a few things you've
got business rules that now have to uh
interact with previous screens that
you've designed so it takes you a little
bit longer to add the same amount of
functionality that you would have taken
you a short amount of time to do at the
start of the system and eventually it
takes really long time to add any
functionality because there's just a lot
of competing different rules there's a
lot of things going on in in the system
that you're working
on and you might think to yourself okay
well this is the time now that we need
to do a rewrite so you go to the
business and you say listen uh we've
just completed our microservice project
that was a that was a great success
we've micros serviced everything um how
about as a reward you let us do a oh I
know we'll call it a modernization
project we'll modernize the system we'll
we'll it's not a rewrite because they
they won't agree to that but we'll
modernize it um and we'll replace the
parts with a new system give us six
months it'll be perfect and the business
will go and say six
months okay yeah we can we can make that
work so you start your rewrite now if we
started it here like where the the
amount of new functionality you can add
is absolutely awful so we timed this re
perfectly what's going to happen is that
instead of adding this bit of
functionality at the top because we're
not adding more functionality that no
longer exists while we're doing the
rewrite so the amount of functionality
we've got stays constant and then we
start rewriting the system again and now
this is a new system essentially it's a
green field system so the amount of
functionality we can add in a short
amount of time time is fantastic this is
the most amazing thing we've ever
done and it's probably going to be
faster than it was originally because
you've spent more time in the business
domain you know more about the business
problems that you're going to experience
and while you were working on the old
system you're probably sitting there
banging your head on the desk thinking
about how you would do things
differently so you're going to be very
productive during this
phase but it's going to take you longer
than six
months why because I'm a developer I
know how we estimate things in fact the
there's probably some correlation
between how good of a developer you are
and how good of an estimator you are if
you're a really good developer you're
probably a really bad estimator and if
you're a good estimator you must be an
awful developer uh I myself am the
world's okayest estimator I've got that
going for me but even if you could
estimate with 100% accuracy so if you if
you took the entire system and you knew
it was going to take you six months to
redo this entire thing it would still be
wrong because with large complex systems
you can't keep all of that context in
your head while you're doing the
estimation process there's a lot that
goes on in these large complex systems
and the chances of it being 100%
documented is almost zero it's a bit
like where that dog from up where we get
hyperfocused on certain things at a time
forgetting about everything else or
every second Tuesday if it happens to
fall on a full moon the business R will
invert and now we now need to pay
customers to use our system for 24 hours
it's those edge cases that make software
development interesting and we often
forget about those while while we doing
uh problem solving of big complex
systems so we're busy working on our
reite and it's been 9 months now after
after we told business that it take six
months and they're going to come to us
and say listen uh we we can't keep doing
this we need there's a new compliance
project coming out gdpr 2.0 has hit we
need to comply by the end of the
year and you you say okay just give us
give us two more months it'll be fine
four months later they come and say okay
this is this is it we're canceling this
modernization it's not a rot we're
canceling this modernization project now
and you you go into the stages of grief
uh where and you you start you
immediately jump to the bargaining phase
and you say okay I'll make you a deal
got an idea what we do is we'll have the
old system that's in production right
and that's working fine people are using
that we'll keep that there and we'll
deploy the parts that we've Rewritten so
far is this sign of familiar at all to
anyone right and well this the users can
use the new system for the parts we have
Rewritten and the old system for the
parts we haven't and then uh we'll we'll
keep them in sync by creating an
integration layer that'll be fine um yes
and you you honestly believe this
because it it feels right you've
invested 10 months of your life trying
to do this rewrite um and you you sort
of forget that now you don't just have
to support one system you've got to
support three systems you have to
support your old Legacy system you have
to support your new system and you have
to support this horrible integration lay
the integration layer is going to be
horrible because it has to talk to the
horrible old system and the longer that
it has to do that the more likelihood
there is that the horrible decisions in
the old system are going to bleed over
into the new system oh William I need
that field in the report by Tuesday
afternoon please can we get it in the
new system and you think okay well yes
I'll just take it through as it is now
and then I'll fix it in the next Sprint
yeah
right but at least we're doing Services
now so on the new side that's great um
it's a bit like trying to build an aane
while you flying it I asked doly to
generate an image of that um and I came
up with this horrifying thing I don't
know why it's got the word dogs on the
side I I don't know what that's about
and it looks a little bit I don't know
is it me or was it the Ryan Air font
under the
engine no
judgment so the second technique that we
can use to make the worst system is we
can try and do a big bang rewrite now I
said big bang rewrites do not work
little asterisk there are two cases
where they do work uh the first case is
when the system is actually just not
large and complex so if you can safely
do the rewrite within a few months it
can work but at that stage you're not
dealing with large complex software
systems you're dealing with a
system uh again you need to sort of make
sure that you've checked your
assumptions about the estimation how
long it's going to take whether you can
do it within that period of time but it
can work if the system isn't actually
that
complicated the second time that it will
work is for your CV um so as soon as you
start the rewrite you you put the latest
and greatest technology uh in your new
project and before you even compile you
add it to your CV as well you start
sending that
out um and that'll that'll work for
you so where are we now we've got three
systems we supporting in production
we've got the old system we've got the
new system and we've got the
monolith cool um it's still not too bad
though we can make this worse let's take
a look at this problem remember why we
had this big drop of performance it was
because we were waiting for things to
finish they hang around longer which
means there's a higher likel of Gen 2
garbage collection we don't want to do
this again we want to make new better
mistakes making the same old mistakes is
boring so what we'll do is instead of
our service calling another service
directly and waiting for a response
we'll be smart we'll do this thing we've
heard about in the microservices space
called cues so we'll introduce a Queue
at the credit card service and our
service a when it needs to call the
credit card service instead of calling
it directly it just takes a message and
puts it on the queue for the credit card
service which means that as soon as the
broker tells our service cool I've got
your message service a can then
terminate and we don't hang around for a
long time so we don't get that Gen 2
garbage collection that sounds great
what could go wrong here well let's have
a look at the credit card service so as
this calls our payment service it takes
messages off the front of the queue and
it says okay I need to charge this
credit card €10 I'll call my payment
provider and do that so our message
flows along from the back of the queue
to the front and it gets to the front
and it says we need to charge Williams
credit card
50 um and we call the payment provider
and something goes wrong probably
because I don't have 50 to my name I
don't know um and we get an exception
and think okay oh well uh well we've
taken that message off of the queue and
it's now
disappeared it doesn't happen often but
I I don't want to say never happens but
it's very rare that I get a business
requirement that I need to lose my
customer money um but if this was that
requirement I'd be doing a great job
here so instead of just losing that
message when we take it off of the queue
what we'll do then is we'll get clever
and we'll think well when I take the
message off of the queue and I try and
process it I'll do it in a in a loop
within a try catch so if it fails I'll
just keep R trying to process that
message and that's that's fine now I
don't lose that message except maybe I'm
maybe there's something wrong with the
payment provider and all I'm doing is
I'm dsing them constantly because I'm
just trying to process the same message
over and over and over again maybe they
charge me per call that I make okay so
now I'll get smarter and I'll think well
what I'll do is I'll introduce some sort
of delay mechanism that if it constantly
fails we'll back off and we'll slow
down okay so we solve that problem but
maybe my credit card will never have 50
available to it and the call will always
fail maybe I put the wrong credit card
number in that message is sitting at the
front of the queue everything behind it
is waiting for its turn to get processed
but this message that'll never get
processed is sitting there blocking
everything okay well easy fix what would
do is we'll introduce a dead letter que
and we'll take that message and we'll
move it to the dead letter queue which
then also means that I now need to make
some software to manage that dead L
queue uh so that I can put those
messages back in production and this is
actually sounding like a really fun
engineering problem and it is a fun
engineering problem because it's what I
do as my day
job this is this is a Sol Problem by n
service mass transit reburst brighter
command there's many options in the just
in the net space that solve this sort of
problem for you and I use uh messaging
as an example because that's what I know
but you can take any sort of example you
want here uh did anybody I'm I don't
know if it's still a thing that the the
young people do these days but back when
I was doing software development in my
day um everybody had their go at writing
an OM mapper so you would have your
little table definition and then it
would generate the SQL scripts to create
the table for you you and they to create
your code file so you could just call
those things everyone did that right so
whether it's that whether it's a front
end framework the chances of your
business needing a such unique use case
is very slim I'm not saying it's
impossible but it's very slim and
there's almost always going to be an off
the shelf framework that does a lot of
what you need even though it's really
cool engineering problems to
solve so the third technique is don't
use offthe shelf Frameworks to help you
do these kinds of
things so what do we have now well we've
got our monolith that we supporting
we've got our new system we supporting
we've got our integration layer that we
supporting and we've got this horrible
smelly buggy framework thing that we
supporting as well along the way so
that's four things that we're doing
instead of actually doing any business
functionality that's pretty
good let's dig a little bit deeper
though and we'll look into more specific
examples so maybe this is a e-commerce
site that we're working on it's amaz no
it's rainforest.com so rainforest.com is
an e-commerce site and you can buy
things things um predominantly products
you know so we'll have a product service
that defines things that you can buy so
maybe something like coffee would have a
title it would have a price associated
with it some images for the product um
where it's in stock a description some
reviews for it and we sort of build this
into our product service and we end up
with an entity that sort of looks a
little bit like this and then our
business comes uses and says we need a
search screen and you go great I've been
waiting for this moment my whole life we
can take our product entity and create a
search screen so if someone searches for
coffee we get a list of all of these
things because we can search through the
name or the description of the products
and we can display all things that have
coffee somewhere in them and that's
great uh see the modernization project
was a success even though it's not
finished
yet but then our product owner comes to
us and says hey I've got an idea now the
correct response when your product owner
comes to you and says I've got an idea
is you tell the product owner please
wait until the next Sprint we can do
this during the Sprint planning session
you escort them out the building once
they've left you fake your own death and
you start a new life somewhere
else but you don't do that and the
product owner says um we've got a theory
that if someone has ordered specifically
consumables before there's a likely High
likelihood that they'll order the same
thing again so we want to show on the
search screen which products a user has
ordered
before and you think oh damn that is a
good
idea
except the order history isn't in the
product service that's in the order
service that you've got so if you want
to display that and you start sort of
getting creative and you're thinking of
ideas um H okay I'll tell you what
product owner if you promise that this
is the only time this is going to happen
we can make this work and they agree of
course of course they do so now you
include the order service in your
product Services search now it doesn't
NE necessarily have to mean that you're
calling two things maybe the product
service is coordinating this uh maybe
you've got a cool API Gateway in place
that'll solve this for you but you're
now invoke involving data from two
different services in in your search
screen but it's okay you deploy this and
it's working and everything's great and
then the next Sprint the product owner
comes to you and says
hey instead of Faking your own death you
listen to them and they say well we want
to give certain customers certain
discounts so if they're a gold customer
maybe want to give them a specific price
and again you think damn that's a really
good
idea can't shoot it down except the
customer status isn't in the order
service and it's not in the product
service either that's in the customer
service and you think to yourself oh I
just fooled myself real good here you
promised product owner and the product
owner is going to say well I didn't
Pinky
Promise so now you include the customer
service in your search screen and
eventually your whole system is blured
over to having all of your different
service boundaries in one request and
search is a good example of this because
search involves looking for things all
over the
place so it might seem like a contrived
example but search is a hard problem to
solve just think how much money Google
throws at the
problem but why is this a problem why
why do we have these cross service
boundary
calls has anybody watched this
video uh there there's a slide at the
end with the URLs and everything but
this is mandatory viewing if you if you
are to attempt microservices it's by
YouTube channel called croam and the
video is called
microservices um I cried the first few
times I watched it because it's just
it's so so beautiful should have won an
Oscar for
something but if we've got our three
different Services right we've got our
service boundaries our product service
our order service and our customer
service These are nice things because we
can represent them as nice little
entities right you can go into a shop
and you can pick up a product you can
expect the product you can look at it
you can put it down you can do the same
same thing with the order like you can
take your invoice your T upep at the end
and you can look at it and you can
inspect it and put it down it's a nice
thing I guess you could pick up
customers and inspect them but I
wouldn't recommend that if you do you do
have to make sure you put them down at
some point though but these are things
these are things that you can interact
with at a physical level when it comes
to software though users don't product
they don't customer they don't
user they they search they check out
they add to cart they do these processes
they verb rather than noun with your
system and if you take your service
boundaries and you define them as nouns
there's a very high likelihood that
you're going to have to do cross-service
communication whenever you're doing
verby things so whenever you're
interacting with the system when you're
shopping there's a high likelihood that
there's going to be cross- service
communication because doing things isn't
just a a thing on its own it's usually a
combination of different puzzle pieces
again I asked darly for a picture of a
puzzle I'm concerned that it doesn't
know what words are because this is not
a puzzle that anyone can
do so to make sure that we have the best
chance of having the most cross-service
communication possible the fourth
technique that we can use is we can make
sure that we Define our service
boundaries based off of nouns and not
verbs it's really hard to make your
service boundaries based off of verbs
but it is so worthwhile if you end up
with your service boundaries being
product policy
claims take some time to reflect on
those and see if maybe there's uh
different ways that you can represent
the actions the behaviors of those
internal service
boundaries right so we've got our
monolith our integration layer our
microservice system this new framework
that's we supporting that's a bit buggy
and broken and we've made sure that all
of our services are defined in such a
way that they're nouns so that there's
as much cross service communication as
we can possibly get how can we make this
worse well let's fix this right we want
to we want to fix things not make them
worse so what we'll do is we'll fix this
instead of having cross service calls
we'll we'll make this a better thing so
instead of having search being a product
thing uh what we'll do is we'll create a
search service right to search is a verb
so this is good uh we've got a good
service boundary there and the search
service can have its own little
representation of the products so
instead of being a product entity it
might be a search product entity which
has some additional fields in there so
whether customer which customers have
ordered this before um specific pricing
for specific customers you know we can
make whatever model we need to represent
the search Behavior within the search
service and this is looking promising
but how do we get the data into the
search service
right well I know we've got Pub sub
right that's cool so what we'll do is
when ever a new product is added to the
product service because the product
service is the source of truthful
products we'll publish an event and then
the search service can subscribe to that
event and it can maintain its own list
of search products and we can do the
same for the customer service when a
customer status changes will product
will publish an event and we can
maintain that list within the search
service and the same for the order
service publish events when someone
orders something anybody tried this
before there's so many problems with
this not least of which is the
duplication of data because that's
that's fine like we can we can justify
that away we're all smart here we're all
Architects so we can say things like
um this is okay
because uh oh the source of Truth for
products is still in the product service
this is just a read model okay so we're
doing cqrs yes this is good uh cqrs
we're publishing events so it's event
sourcing as well we're doing cqs event
sourcing and definitely bounded context
so it's dddd so we're doing DDD cqs
event sourcing this is a good thing this
is a fun system to work on and people
believe
you but even if the duplication of data
wasn't a problem which it sort of is um
the biggest problem with this is you
still have tight coupling between your
components as an example if the customer
service changes its business rules that
says well instead of giving special
pricing to Gold customers we want to
give special pricing to the top 100
customers the customer service makes its
change internally and then suddenly the
search service doesn't work because it's
still listening for events that says
customer status has changed not well
customers moved from 99 to
100 we've got tight coupling between the
business logic of the search service and
the customer service in that case so
even if the duplication of data wasn't a
concern the coupling is a bigger
problem
we can fix this though um and I'm going
to show you a technique to fix this but
I want to be clear I'm not saying this
is a good technique I'm also not saying
this is a bad technique I'm just saying
hey here's a thing put it in your
toolbox if it works for you great if it
doesn't also don't just use it
everywhere and the thing that it relies
off of is that when you're dealing with
software uh we've got the 4 plus1 view
of software right and it means that the
logical boundaries of your system
doesn't have to match the physical
deployment boundaries of your system you
can have the logical boundaries be
intact while breaking that apart at
deployment
time so we're going to look at something
known as the engine pattern so we'll
first of all replace our search service
with a search engine because that just
sounds right doesn't it a search engine
is much better than a search
service and the search engine is going
to expose three interfaces so the first
interface it's going to expose is
something called I find products which
just takes in a filter and splits back a
list of products it's then going to
expose a i price products interface
which surprise surprise gives you a
price for a product for a specific user
and then an ey track orders which just
says true or false if someone has
ordered something before or not so the
search engine takes these three
interfaces and compiles it into an
assembly and puts it on a local nougat
feed or something or some type of
internal package
manager which means then that how do we
use this so our product service can go
and and take that Nate feed or that
package from wherever it is and it can
implement a class called product finder
and this class implements the iind
products interface the customer service
can do the same with the status pricer
so the status pricer class can Implement
an ey price products interface and the
order service can Implement an order
history
class how do we deploy this or how do we
bring it all together without
introducing
coupling as part of your build process
when you check in your code why don't
you take that product finder class
compile it into into its own assembly
and then take that assembly that dll and
paste it into the folder of the search
engine so the search engine when it says
oh I need to do a search can say hey net
please give me all of the classes in my
app domain that implement the iin
products interface so in this case the
search engine doesn't have to know about
the product service it just knows oh
here's a class that implements this
interface so now I can ask this class
for a list of products that match the
search text that I've put in that
product class knows that it needs to
talk to the product service
database and we can do the same with the
status pricer so the status pricer can
be compiled into an assembly and put
into the search engines folder the
search engine can then say give me all
of the instances of give me all of the
classes Implement that Implement ey
price products and apply that to the
list of products that you got from the
previous uh product finder class and
then the same happens with the order
history class we're making three queries
here but there's a a big distinction
between what we had here and what we had
with uh the cross service communication
because the product finder doesn't need
to know anything about the status price
so it doesn't need to know anything
about the audit history it doesn't need
to know anything other than I'm making a
query to my database and here's a list
of products that
match if the customer service changes
this business rule and says well instead
of the status given special pricing we
want the top 100 customers to have
special pricing the customer service
makes the change logically within its
boundary it instead of shipping out a
status pricer class it ships out a
ranking
pricer and places that in the search
engine folder the change only happened
logically within the customer service
but it's now affected the way that we
display results in the search engine we
don't have that same coupling before so
even though we still making multiple
calls to multiple Services logically
those calls aren't crossing any service
boundaries so we have the uh we have the
Loc coupling that we were looking for
there another nice side effect of this
is that you're not only limited to uh
the product service only doing the
product finder for instance the product
service could say well every day I'm
going to choose 10 items at random and
these 10 items are going to be heavily
discounted so the product finder or the
product service can Implement a daily
deal pricer and ship that off so when
the search engine says I need to display
the prices it now gets two instances of
classes that can change the prices of
the products
maybe the order service wants to do a
bulk discount if someone has ordered
nine of these items before the 10th one
is 90% off you the order service can
create a bulk Discounter that implements
the high price products and send that
off to the search engine none of these
things know anything about any of the
other components there's very low
coupling between them and all of the
changes that have to happen happen
within the service boundaries of each of
these
things and the thing that this relies
off of is that you don't need to have
the same logical system boundaries as
you do with the physical system
boundaries you can have those be
different so if you want to make sure
that you get it wrong make sure that you
conflate those two together so that you
don't accidentally deploy things uh
differently so we've had five techniques
uh the first is just to put an HTTP call
in front of everything so we can have a
nice great distributor monolith uh the
second is to do a big bang rewrite
because what's better than having one
system to maintain well having three
systems is better the third technique is
to make sure that we do all of our cool
things ourselves because that's actually
the fun engineering work that we want to
do and it is really rewarding for us
it's just a Pity that the poor business
doesn't get any value out of
it um make sure that you use nouns
instead of verbs for your service
boundaries and then conflate your
logical and your physical deployment
boundaries together for maximum effect
so that you can't work around any of
these coupling
issues uh I'm going to leave this slide
up for a little bit while I talk so I
want to I want to sort of pre-answer a
question that I often get about this I
finish quite a bit early um but I almost
always get a question either directly
from the audience or they come to ask me
afterwards of well thanks for showing us
what not to do but um can't you show us
what we should do instead and I think
unfortunately that's a bit of a failing
in the way that I that I present this
talk so the it should be obvious that
the talk is not about what you should do
to make successful microservices but at
the same time and slightly obviously
it's also not about what you shouldn't
do to be successful with microservices
so all of these five techniques I listed
them as guaranteed fail but they're
not right you they're all very valuable
important techniques the Strangler fig
pattern is a very valuable tool that you
can use but it has its downsides it
doesn't help you with any coupling
concerns that you've got it doesn't help
you tease out important complex parts of
your system it's really good at taking
bits of your system that are welld
designed and well encap at and moving
them
elsewhere but you need to get to that
point
first not every offal frame or not every
problem has an off the shell frame
that's going to work but chances are
there's probably something that's going
to be avilable there so when I say these
are the top five techniques to get
things wrong that's not necessarily true
the intention here is so that we're all
smart we're all in this room we're at
NDC we're trying to learn we're trying
to get better at our
craft but there's downsides to all of
these things so when you use these
techniques don't be afraid to use them
they're very valuable but think about
what the downside effects are and weigh
that up against what benefits you get
from it maybe it's okay to have cross-
service communication because you get a
very clear way of talking with your
users about the problem domain maybe a
single language is more important to you
than having uh fewer cross- service
calls just be aware of all of the side
effects or not not the side effects the
downsides of these types of techniques
rather than Building Systems in the the
a horrible quality I don't want to see
any systems that you people build I want
to see you guys build systems up in this
side of the
segment so you don't have to come to
people like me to help you with these
things and with that I am done are there
any questions you can always talk to me
afterwards I'm very very excited to talk
about Bad Code so you can grab me after
if you want as
well great thank you everyone